apparently actor Robert De Niro is in
the middle of a big lawsuit against a
former assistant Janeiro claims the
assistant embezzled money from him and
binge-watched
fifty five episodes of friends in four
days while on the job fifty five
episodes of friends in four days Wow
supposedly she was supposed to be
working for DeNiro now that seemed like
a lot thought I thought to myself I
think I know someone who could blow that
number away someone who watches a ton of
television at work always has I'm
talking about my assistant Sona
yeah yesterday ya know you think I'm
kidding I'm not kidding I'm serious she
could destroy this record in my opinion
so yesterday on the show I challenged
Sona to beat the record of 55 episodes
of friends in four days or less she said
no problem no problem actually she was
watching friends episodes at work when I
brought the idea up to her let's go live
to her desk now to check on her progress
Sona Conan here
[Applause]
okay gonna see a sauna sauna you took
this challenge very seriously how many
episodes if you watched so far are
friends um I think that I'm on episode
I'm on the 29th episode right now okay
and you just started yesterday I am I'm
one episode ahead of schedule
okay alright and which episode are you
watching now I'm watching season 5
episode 4 yeah she's the one where
Phoebe hates PBS okay alright
have you taken a break at all in all
this watching of friends I did I took a
I took a quick kind of like it I
probably a two-hour break okay yeah I
was what you do during that I watched
four episodes of [ __ ] scream wait a
minute your break you didn't go outside
and take a walk and get something to
drink
you watched four episodes of [ __ ] scream
yeah well you don't know what I'm
watching so I figured I might as well
cram in a bunch of stuff that I'm
binging anyway so that you know okay
alright
how is it going juggling work and
watching TV at the same time it's fine I
think that uh I think that I'm uh wait a
minute what did you just get I got my
sushi order okay yay you're getting
sushi yes
can I just ask you and I'm being serious
about this who's paying for the sushi
you're paying for this use your credit
card you have my credit card yeah very
nice okay how much is the sushi do you
think it's not cheap I'm kind of you
know I am I'm confined to my desk I
figured that this is a work expense so I
just went crazy with it alright okay so
thank you for this sushi alright okay
once you beat the record a you're gonna
stop right there at the moment you've
beaten the record I think that I'm gonna
tell you that I haven't beaten the
record and then just keep watching okay
okay
this is your doing you did this you told
me to do this and so I'm do I suggested
the idea and you were all over it yeah
I'm just curious how are you able to do
all these up watch all these episodes of
friends and still do work for me at the
same time I am NOT doing my other duties
is I am prioritizing this and then just
kind of letting other stuff not happen
okay
what about that medicine I asked you to
get that saves my life I didn't get it I
didn't do it I don't do anything you
asked me to do okay yeah that's alright
that's alright it's a
cholesterol-lowering drug that could
have a heart attack at any second all
right we're gonna you better get back to
work we will check back in with Sona
tomorrow so I'm assessing everybody